auf jeden fall ganz ganz wichtig ich
glaube resozialisierung ist ein element
also wichtiges thema gerade was die acht
angeht wir sehen uns in amerika ist
funktioniert nicht also zelle auf
schlüssel wegschmeißen das gibt es nicht
oder dreimal 100 jahre geben ich denke
einfach
harte strafen sind wichtig ich spreche
aus erfahrung aber auch im vollzug also
wenn die strafe dann vollzogen wird muss
es immer jemanden geben der einen
alternativen aufzeigt zwei wege zeigt
eben auch die chance gibt sich wieder zu
integrieren so zu resozialisieren
ich glaube das ist ganz ganz wichtig
ansonsten funktioniert es nicht und dann
wären die gäste immer voller statt
weniger und ich glaube das ist ein kein
interesse schon gar nicht der polizei
und der gesellschaft glaube ich von da
ist das ein ganz ganz wichtiger baustein
und ich spreche da du dich aus erfahrung
sie saßen ja sechseinhalb jahre in
isolationshaft sogar wie war die zeit
für sie und wer hat sie dort auf den
richtigen weg gebracht was erhard muss
ich sagen das ist eine maximale mentale
belastung ich glaube das würde auch
nicht jeder durchstehen ich wusste es
auch nicht das weiß man erst im
nachhinein ja aber der situation
geschuldet der sicherheitslage damals
weitere flucht ich denke dass da ja und
ja es ist halt schwierig gewesen
trotzdem war ich in der lage mich so
selbst ein bisschen auch aufzufangen ich
habe sehr viel gelesen habe ich mit der
prozess war auch sehr lange fünf jahre
jünger wo ist erst 29 10 zu ende
gegangen von 14 bis 29 10 von daher war
ich da auch sehr viel immer ein thema
hat mich selbst mit den akten
beschäftigt war ja auch ein sehr
dynamischer prozess muss man sagen ja
und so habe ich die zeit darum bekommen
ihr habt viel auch gelesen dass ich mit
mir selbst auseinandergesetzt es gab
dort einen sozialarbeiter der mir sehr
geholfen hat damals und das war sehr
sehr wichtig deswegen meinte ich auch es
ist wichtig dass man jemand hat der ist
ein rausch führt aus dieser schwierigen
und dunklen zeit muss man dazu sagen es
ist keine schöne zeit egal wie man sich
das schön redet und ja das war nicht
sehr einfach aber es war machbar und
schaffbar deswegen finde ich auch für
harte strafen sind wichtig möglich sie
sind wirklich sehr sehr wichtig aber
parallel laufen immer alternativen und
auch möglichkeiten geben sie wieder dort
raus zu holen wenn sie ihre strafe
abgesessen haben für diejenigen die es
nicht wissen warum saßen sehen ich wurde
verurteilt für den experten maut damals
den berühmt-berüchtigten wettbüro mord
in reinickendorf wo es eigentlich mit
einbegriffen in den laden gegangen sind
dort einen konkurrenten erschossen haben
also eine person aus dem umkreis von uns
oder von mir damals und bin dort mit als
mittäter verurteilt worden hab mich aber
dazu entschieden mich aus diesem studium
zu lösen weil es einfach der falsche weg
ist dass das kein weg er sich die langen
armen als großer habt keine angst so
etwas nicht nein das ist eine
individuelle entscheidung
traf
die strafprozessordnung gibt es vor ob
sie dann wirklich auch in anspruch
genommen wird von einem gericht das
entscheidet ist immer individuell hier
jedes gericht hat hier freien
beweiswürdigung und entscheiden dann ob
sie es dann für notwendig halten oder
auch nicht naja ist ja war einfach meine
war eine richtige entscheidung die
schwierige auch für mich es war auch ein
heute muss man dazu sagen ich war nicht
immer dem staat wirklich nett
gegenübergestanden auch die polizisten
muss man dazu sagen klar heute ist die
perspektive eine andere ich habe viele
freunde beim landeskriminalamt
mittlerweile arbeite auch ein gewinn
zusammen im austausch versuche workshops
zu geben jugendlichen die so ein
bisschen auf dem falschen weg sind so
die alternative zu bieten oder auch ein
bisschen den als lebens beispiel den
spiegel vorzuhalten so kann es auch
funktioniert so geht es in die richtung
wenn du nicht wirklich mal aufhörst
genau richtig ist führt zunächst am ende
des tages ja und ja das war der richtige
weg ich würde natürlich nie wieder mich
entscheiden in eine struktur diese zu
gehen aber ich würde den schritt immer
wieder tun also ich bereue nicht sagen
wir mal so ja von der iss war ein
wichtiger schritt und hat ja auch dazu
geführt dass dann auch wirklich
verurteilung stattgefunden haben die
hätten so glaube ich nicht stattgefunden
weil die beweislage schwierig war und
es wurde ja gerade schon angesprochen
dass die jetzt angeles ja nicht immer
besonders netze polizei sind ich glaube
sogar in manchen bereichen geht die
polizei auch nur mit wirklich 100
schaffen kann man sagen ob ich mit einer
großen mannschaft um überhaupt noch nie
ist es jetzt für sie wenn sie neben
sitzen nehmen sie die reue ab wie
empfinden sie das also habe ich jetzt
nicht gerade ein bisschen ein bisschen
darüber darüber gewundert sie haben
jetzt gerade berichtet über die zeit im
gefängnis und die resozialisierung sind
aber kein wort darüber verloren dass sie
unter umständen sich auch mal gedanken
darüber gemacht haben dass das was sie
vorher gemacht haben und jetzt nicht nur
in der struktur der hells angels
irgendwie irgendwie bedauern oder oder
oder bereuen das stimmt mich ehrlich
gesagt ein bisschen nachdenkt hätte mir
gewünscht dass das zu diesem paket mit
dazu gehört
die hells angels wir natürlich auch
insbesondere als polizei auch tote zu
beklagen also ich erinnere an diesen an
diesen toilettentür motto der wurde der
kollege bei einer hausdurchsuchung
stumpf mit dem mit dem sportgewehr durch
die durch die tür erschossen wurde
insofern in bochum ja insofern insofern
ist es für mich als als als polizist mit
leib und seele schwierig mich mich mit
solcher situation auseinanderzusetzen
ich gibt ganz offen zu ich finde es gut
wenn menschen die wegen einer wegen
einer straftat auch wegen einer schweren
straftat im gefängnis saßen dann
resozialisiert werden und vor allen
dingen auch tatsächlich resozialisiert
werden und eben nicht die
resozialisierung dann irgendwann
irgendwann abbrechen und wieder genau in
dieses fahrwasser kommen was dazu
geführt hat dass es im gefängnis endete
ich will gerne was dazu sagen weil ich
es wichtig ist natürlich bereue ich das
sonst werde ich diesen schritt hätte ich
nicht gehen können das ist ganz ganz
wichtig das ist vielleicht das hinten
runtergefallen um das mal klarzustellen
ja also ich hab auch der der
opferfamilie auch im brief geschrieben
das war mir persönlich sehr wichtig der
leider denn auch in der presse genannt
ist auch bei ihnen in der zeit
unglaublich in der bild zeitung war
deren entscheidung aber trotzdem ist
natürlich reue und es auch empathie in
dem sich gespräch das auch in meinem
buch was jetzt herauskommt na ja wofür
sie eine therapie ja klar aber die hat
doch schon vorher stattgefunden dadurch
dass der prozessor wirklich so lange wie
lange lief hatte ich ja sehr viel zeit
ja auch zwangsläufig mit mir auseinander
zu setzen und da habe ich mich schon
maximal glaube ich auch selbst
therapiert weit man muss auch dazu sagen
dass es sich bei jedem wichtigen bei
jedem spielsüchtigen was auch immer die
die erkenntnis muss erst bei ihm selbst
anfangen sonst bringt es nichts was kann
man sonst welche dinge sozialarbeiter
oder worker oder auch sechs polizisten
die auf gut 1 1 reden das sind ja keine
bösen menschen die tun mir auch so iris
mögliche was sie können wenn man es
nicht selbst verstanden hat bringt es
nichts das breite ab ja ja ist gut und
dann geht es wie sie schon sagen bricht
das dann wieder aus also wenn ich mir
die krankheit aber mit wieder rückfällig
wie auch immer und das muss halt
nachhaltig sein was fängt dann immer bei
ihm selber an und das war die zeit die
ich halt hoffentlich ich bin 100
prozentig dass ich sehr positiv genutzt
habe um mich da so maximal auch
nachhaltig zu lösen und ich bin ja nicht
komisch grünen kriminell gewesen sondern
habe mich dann etwas verrannt wo ich
dann später auch viel auch strafe
absitzen musste und auch meine rechnung
dafür bezahlen ihre vergangenheit nicht
als kriminell bezeichnen naja natürlich
war ich dem seine kriminelle klar aber
ich war jetzt nicht ich habe jetzt nicht
jahrzehntelang drohen verkauft habe
irgendwelche leute irgendwie süchtig
gemacht was auch immer ich war auf meine
art und weise schon kriminell und hab
straftaten begangen ja aber es ist
differenziert das schon immer ich bin
ich irgendwie dass ich da sag ich ja
auch immer zu mir selber ich bin ich
klar machen rotlicht arbeite ja als
wirtschafter das ist ja jetzt nicht
wirklich illegal muss halt immer schon
wie das vonstatten findet es auch weiter
besteuerte beruf prostitution etc ist
natürlich immer so halblegal muss man
auch dazu sagen aber ist auch kein
million dem ich mich jetzt mehr bewege
ich nehme noch maximal abstand davon
habe es auch schon öfter angesprochen
auch in der öffentlichkeit aber am ende
des tages sehe ich mich nicht als
rückfällig gefährdet weil ich einfach
auch mit dem thema abgeschlossen hat und
gesagt hat so möchte ich nicht durch die
welt laufen ich möchte jeden akzeptieren
so wie er ist und auch seine
berechtigung daseinsberechtigung geben
was ja auch in diesem milieu nicht
stattfindet wenn dann sind das alles so
leute die man irgendwie für sich nutzen
kann zum vorteil rein opportunistisch
und das so denke ich nicht mehr und wie
gesagt ich habe eine enge verbindung zum
landeskriminalamt
wir arbeiten dort eng zusammen teilweise
und habe auch privat freunde dort und
das ist das richtige ich kann nur jedem
empfehlen der diese strukturen ist und
dort zweifel hat man sollte diesen weg
gehen wie schwer auch ist das ist die
konsequenz daraus der entscheidung zuvor
das muss man einfach akzeptieren das ist
so auch dann die haftstrafe deswegen
haben sie angst vor rache weil sie gegen
ihre kollegen ausgesagt haben angst ich
bin kein ängstlicher mensch muss dazu
sagen angst ist und so eine art
angeles wenn ich medienberichten glauben
schenken er zum teil ja der linke arm
das ist teil meiner geschichte auch
einmal ein bisschen bisschen übertrieben
aber es ist halt meine geschichte die
waldseer prägen für mich auch jetzt
werden sie sich nicht über tätowieren
der neuen einheit und dementsprechend
bleibt es da wo es ist was ich noch
zurückkommen wollte zu dem was sagen sie
mich immer noch gefragt werde was davor
das habe ich jetzt glaube ich durch das
habe sie angst haben
angst ich bin kein ängstlicher mensch
ich bin wach nach der vorstellung der
polizeischutz habe dort auch meine
einschätzung der beamten und bin im
engen austausch
habe auch ein bisschen begleitungen wie
auch immer da will ich jetzt nicht näher
darauf eingehen weil es einfach
aber ich habe keine angst ich meide
gewisse orte um die listen dem ich mich
nicht mehr bewegen und
angst hängt ja auch wissen sie ich habe
jetzt viele jahre auch qualität
lebensqualität einmischen müssen müssen
zurecht ja das will ich jetzt gar nicht
irgendwie schön reden oder mich da
irgendwie aus der verantwortung nehmen
aber ich lasse ihnen die sie jetzt immer
der freiheit und auch nachdem ich jetzt
ein neues kapitel positives meiner
meinung nach eingeschlagen habe nicht
nehmen dem ich mir jetzt vom englischen
leuten jetzt angst einjagen lassen und
wie die lebensqualität maximal nehmen
von daher ich bin wachsam ich bin
aufmerksam und
zweite chancen definitiv weil ich habe
auch viele freunde
meinen kreise die auch im gefängnis
waren vielleicht nicht solche sachen
autodiebstahl oder etc
und die daneben aber die wurden
aufgefangen das ist das ding sie hatten
das ding ist sie sind raus gekommen und
waren dann bei uns und sind bei uns
geblieben also solche verbrechen nicht
rückfällig geworden dadurch auch nicht
rückfällig weil wir dann sozusagen wie
so eine art familie waren oder sind also
da gibt es schon einige die
auch
sachen machen die man nicht machen
sollte aber eben wenn eben der halt
erhalt es wichtig zu sagen sie wollen
zwar nicht aber sie würden ihn aufnehmen
ich würde aber
ihnen wurde sicher gefallen deswegen
würde es ja nur machen wenn es ein nein
sowas